[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hellwig
silvester
2021 guten abend ihnen allen und
willkommen ruedi zahner ist auch dabei
für den sport hallo schön gemacht und
das sind einige unserer themen heute
erste neujahrsansprache vom neuen
kanzler olaf scholz ruft zur solidarität
in der pandemie
ausstieg aus dem atomstrom wie geplant
gehen in der nacht in deutschland drei
atomkraftwerke vom netz
und party ins neue jahr sydney hat schon
silvester gefeiert die große fernsehshow
in berlin geht erst noch los das
alte jahr geht mit einer premiere zu
ende zum ersten mal kommt die
neujahrsansprache von olaf scholz sein
großer wunsch für das neue jahr bleiben
wir zusammen eine starke gemeinschaft
halte widersprüche aus sagt der
bundeskanzler
wenn wir einander zuhören wenn die hitze
hat mehr
die aussichten sind wie sie sind das
jahr war wie es war hochwasser im sommer
pandemie von anfang bis ende
der neue bundeskanzler sie trotzdem
erfreuliches die gesellschaft habe 20 21
solidarität bewiesen manche beklagen in
diesen tagen unsere gesellschaft sei
gespalten ich möchte hier mit aller
deutlichkeit sagen das gegenteil ist
richtig unser land steht zusammen
was ich überall wahrnehme das ist eine
riesige solidarität das ist
überwältigende hilfsbereitschaft das ist
ein neues zusammenrücken und unterhaken
der größte teil seiner rede gilt im
impfen olaf scholz ist für eine
impfpflicht von der spricht er heute
nicht stattdessen ein appell lassen sie
sich impfen
ich weiß dass manche einer und manche
eine skeptisch ist sich sorgt die
impfung könnte negative folgen haben
inzwischen sind allerdings fast vier
milliarden menschen auf der ganzen welt
geimpft ohne größere nebenwirkung ein
dank geht an alle die für das
allgemeinwohl arbeiten eine bitte an
alle die beschränkung weiter anzunehmen
und ein bisschen selbst beschwörung ist
auch dabei wir brechen auf in eine neue
zeit eine zeit gut wird wenn wir sie
aktiv gestalten dann ist macht ein
unterschied dass wir unser schicksal
entschlossen selbst in die hand nehmen
für das neue jahr wünsche ich ihnen
alles gute vor allem gesundheit
ein großer wunsch für 2022
bleiben wir zusammen
viele appelle ans wir gefühl das ist das
grundmotiv der ersten neujahrsansprache
von olaf scholz
die komplette ansprache gibt es hier
direkt nach uns und jederzeit können sie
die erste neujahrsansprache von
bundeskanzler scholz natürlich auch in
unserer zdf heute app anschauen
neues jahr neue hoffnung einige
virologen zeigen sich mit blick auf die
pandemie vorsichtig optimistisch so auch
christian drosten von der berliner
charité er verwies im zdf auf daten aus
südafrika und england sorgen mache ihm
allerdings die große zahl der
ungeimpften in deutschland aktuell
meldet das robert-koch-institut
41 1240 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
323 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage incidents
liegt bei
214,9 allerdings sind die zahlen wegen
der feiertage immer noch unvollständig
hierzulande lassen sich viele gerade zum
dritten mal gegen korona impfen die
auffrischimpfung israel startet schon
mit der vierten dosis zunächst bekommen
nur immungeschwächte und menschen ab 60
den zweiten booster außerdem
medizinisches personal
auch in israel breitet sich die omikron
variante aus aktuell werden rund 5.000
neuinfektionen gemeldet so viele wie
seit drei monaten nicht mehr
nicht nur corona beunruhigt auch der
ukraine konflikt macht sorgen zum
zweiten mal in diesem monat hat
us-präsident beiden gestern abend mit
kremlchef putin gesprochen für den fall
eines russischen einmarsch drohte beiden
mit harten sanktionen und forderte eine
rückkehr zur diplomatie putin warnte
sanktionen wären ein großer fehler mitte
januar wird weiter verhandelt
schwere waldbrände im winter sind
ungewöhnlich aber nach monatelanger
dürre haben sich im us bundesstaat
colorado kleinere feuer rasend schnell
ausgebreitet
bei stürmischem wind fraßen sich die
flammen in zwei städte nordwestlich von
denver
34.000 bewohner mussten fliehen mehr als
500 häuser brannten nieder der
gouverneur von colorado löste
katastrophenalarm aus
jetzt zu einem wichtigen termin in
sachen energiewende heute gehen drei der
letzten sechs atomkraftwerke in
deutschland vom netz unter dem eindruck
der katastrophe im japanischen fukushima
2011 hatte die damalige regierung den
schrittweisen ausstieg besiegelt heute
also das ende für die akw in brokdorf in
schleswig-holstein in grohnde in
niedersachsen und gundremmingen in
bayern simon kann z
wöchentlich treffen sie sich zur
mahnwache vor dem atomkraftwerk
gundremmingen aber so viele wie heute
waren sie schon lange nicht mehr thomas
wolf ist seit mehr als 30 jahren dabei
beim anti akw protest heute ist für ihn
ein besonderer tag das ist natürlich
riesig große erleichterung es gibt keine
gefahr mehr oder weniger gefahr ist wird
kein atommüll produziert es ist also
innerlich ist das familienfest neben
gundremmingen gehen heute zwei weitere
akw vom netz ende 2022 ist dann ganz
schluss wenn die kernkraftwerke emsland
isar 2 und neckarwestheim 2 folgen das
ende der atomkraft provoziert eine
debatte über die richtige reihenfolge
denn während die kernkraftwerke
schließen laufen klimaschädliche
kohlekraftwerke erst einmal weiter
kernenergie ist die energie die co2 frei
auch sensationell günstig diese
kraftwerke sind sehr preisgünstig und
vor allem sehr zuverlässig energie
liefern auch wenn die sonne nicht
scheint und der wind nicht weht die
energiewende bleibt eine herausforderung
80 erneuerbare bis 2030 das ist der plan
der ampelkoalition leicht wird das nicht
wir müssen im bereich der photovoltaik
den ausbau jährlich mindestens
verdreifachen und auch bei onshore wind
müssen wir etwa verdoppeln also das ist
sehr sehr ehrgeizig
die mahnwache in gundremmingen soll es
übrigens weiterhin geben thomas wolf und
seine mitstreiter wollen an den atom
müll erinnern der hier entstanden ist
und für den es noch keine lösung gibt
silvester 2021 wie schon im vergangenen
jahr heißt das feiern im kleinen rahmen
ohne große knallerei und geeint voll
wohl vor allem in einem wunsch dass 2022
wieder normaler wird wie sich die
hauptstadt auf den jahreswechsel
vorbereitet zeigt roman leskovar
schlange stehen vor feinkostläden am
vormittag trotz omikron vormarsch wollen
viele auf einen versöhnlichen
jahresausklang nicht ganz verzichten
partys sind tabu aber ein bisschen
feierlich soll es schon werden wir haben
gäste da es ist recht und wir werden
dann am abend gemeinsam das essen
bisschen was trinken und dann schauen ob
wir noch irgendwo ins freie gehen
vielleicht sieht nur paketen oder so
meine frau schwanger hat und deswegen
feiern war ganz gemütlich im kleinen
kreis sie kommen aus braunschweig heute
auch wieder zurück und feiern wir uns zu
hause mit freunden größere silvestergala
es fast überall abgesagt heißt es vom
berliner gaststättenverband dieses hotel
plant immerhin ein buffet vor kroner kam
weit über 100 gäste jetzt muss es bei 50
bleiben tanz ist verboten stadt vom dj
kommt die musik vom pianisten
kostendeckend ist das nicht das paar so
vieles nicht kostendeckend dieses jahr
aber es war uns doch wichtig dass wir
unseren hausgästen die ferienhaus haben
dann doch einen schönen abend machen
möchten auch das feuerwerk bleibt wie im
vorjahr eingeschränkt über 50 bürger
verbotszonen gelten berlin bald größere
ansammlungen unfälle oder rangeleien
sollen verhindert werden die polizei
kündigt kontrollen an wir haben
insgesamt 1600 kolleginnen und kollegen
im einsatz die sich genau dieser zonen
annehmen werden die überprüfen werden
und darauf achten werden dass die
verbote dort ein gehalt wer ohnehin
lieber drinnen bleiben möchte ist beim
zdf bestens aufgehoben deutschlands
größte silvesterfeier am brandenburger
tor wird auch diesmal live übertragen ab
20 uhr 15
und mit andrea kiewel und johannes b
kerner hallo ihr zwei nach berlin was
habt ihr nach hervor
wer also erst mal werden wir versuchen
möglichst trocken ins neue jahr zu
kommen das ist schon ein etwas
schwierigeres unterfangen denn hier
regnet sich nur in berlin sondern egal
wie und warum wir uns drehen regen kommt
irgendwie immer von vorne aber wir
wollen nicht alleine bleiben wir wollen
mit unseren zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern ein bisschen gewohnheit geben
wenn man ein hashtag eingerichtet danke
20 21 einige werden wofür ich danke ja
aber es gibt in diesem jahr viele
menschen die anderen danken möchten und
mit allen zusammen wollen wir eine gute
party haben hier am brandenburger tor
und klasse livemusik michael patrick
kelly ist bei uns wälster art garfunkel
und sein sohn ist es ein bisschen wie du
und ich marianne rosenberg adel tawil
glasperlenspiel und dann development
nach evans es bei uns ja und für 00 uhr
für silvester once was ganz besonderes
ausgedacht aber wir fangen schon früher
an wie gesagt viertel nach acht live im
zdf ich drücke euch den daumen wünsche
alles gute und schicke grüße nach berlin
während wir uns gerade erst langsam
waren laufend knallten ganz weit im
osten schon vor stunden die sektkorken
doch auch dort gab es oft nur eine
eingeschränkte sause wie tobias häfner
zeigt
feuerwerk wegen der sommer brandgefahr
eher spärlich dafür strahlt die
metropole auckland im lichterglanz ganz
weit unten ganz weit im osten des
pazifik wissen die neuseeländer nun
schon wie sich
2022 anfühlt
der große nachbar australien wagt es
trotz corona wieder pompös pyrotechniker
zeigen über sydney harbour bridge was
sie so können bleib dabei sein ging aber
an den populärsten aussichtspunkten nur
mit ticket impfung dringend gewünscht
zwei stunden später japan dort nutzten
viele die späte uhrzeit auch für etwas
innere einkehr die tempel überall im
land sehr gut besucht und stimmungsvoll
illuminiert
politisch ist die frühere britische
kolonie hongkong längst fest im griff
der chinesischen führung aber beim thema
silvester blitz das alte erbe noch voll
auf klassische musik und mega show um
mitternacht vor der vielleicht
prächtigsten hochhauskulisse der welt
das pandemie jahr 2021 wird so
unaufhaltsam in richtung westen stunde
um stunde ausgelöscht und nicht wenige
wünschen sich wohl dass es der
nachfolger
2022 besser macht
[Musik]
springer jedenfalls geben ganz optimist
haben einen guten lauf gerade oder guten
flug müsste man besser sagen
erfolgreicher jahresabschluss für zwei
deutsche skispringer der sechsmalige
weltmeister markus eisenbichler gewinnt
die qualifikation für das
neujahrsspringen in garmisch
partenkirchen wird gab spitzenreiter
karl geiger überzeugt mit platz drei
die emotionen des siegers markus
eisenbichler lässt seine formdelle
hinter sich und gewinnt die
qualifikation von garmisch partenkirchen
mit einem sprung auf 137 meter
ganz sicher aber es würde immer besser
es kommen immer mehr vertrauen in
ähnlichen sphären wie eisenbichler
bewegt sich karl geiger der fünfte der
gesamtwertung bei der
vierschanzentournee wird dritter
zwischen den beiden deutschen liegt noch
tournee-spitzenreiter rio kobayashi aus
japan
verheißungsvolle voraussetzungen für das
erste springen im neuen jahr
und das neuer springen morgen dann von
13 uhr 45 an live hier im zdf
skilangläuferin katharina henrich aus
oberwiesenthal belegte auf der dritten
etappe der tour de ski in oberstdorf
einen guten sechsten rang den sieg und
die gesamtführung holt sich jessica
dickens aus den usa
zum jahresabschluss glänzt die beste
deutsche langläuferin derzeit katharina
heinig mit ihrem besten ergebnis in der
freien technik rang sechs im massenstart
über 10 kilometer hält die 25 jährige
immer den kontakt zur führungsgruppe im
zielsprint fehlt ihr aber wie sie selbst
sagt im vergleich zu den anderen die
gute technik denn hennig ist eine
klassik spezialistin es gewinnt die us
amerikanerin jessica die jeans bei den
männern feierte der norweger johannes
klar wo in oberstdorf einen souveränen
sieg friedrich noch überzeugt als
zwölfter erfüllt dadurch die norm für
die olympischen spiele in peking
der letzte sportblock 20 21 war das
babor ja stimmt lang fast wehmütig
wäre heute nicht silvester cam glatt
frühlingsgefühle auf es ist viel zu warm
und das bleibt auch erstmal so die
detaillierte vorhersage hat gleich
katharina fa
mir bleibt jetzt noch ihnen im namen der
gesamten heute -redaktion danke zu sagen
für ihr interesse in diesem jahr
außerdem wünschen wir ihnen allen
zuversicht und ein gesundes und
glückliches
2022 alles gute und bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend das jahr 2021 war mit 9,1
grad 0,2 grad kälter als das vieljährige
klimatologische mittel der jahre 1991
bis 2020 mit geht dieses jahr zu ende
ins neue jahr rutschen werden sie
allenfalls im äußersten süden bei 1 grad
da bildet sich auch mal nebel im norden
fällt regen und die temperaturen sinken
auf 12 7 grad und morgen fällt
vormittags noch etwas regen hier
zwischen der ostseeküste und aus sachsen
im norden ist es eher stärker bewölkt
richtung südwesten aber strahlt die
sonne bei milden temperaturen von 9 bis
14 grad ab sonntag wird es dann von tag
zu tag wechselhafter regnerischer
windiger und ganz allmählich auch ein
bisschen kühler die wünsche für das neue
jahr vielleicht mehr zu bemerken als zu
beurteilen meer zu beginnen als
beizubehalten alles gute für 2022